okay this one okay so
usually to to explain why i picked this
one usually i'm like a very much a
vanilla guy you know two too happy
fantastic but this one was the one
hentai that made me realize
man maybe crazy girls are [ __ ] hot
man i mean look i i
the moment i saw this i was like of
course god's into this because this girl
is literally one step away from
every one of god's favorite tsundere
account i mean
okay this is one step above the tsundere
character okay because you talked about
reverse rape earlier and like i feel
like this wasn't reverse right this what
this was this was like reverse
mind break you know this is like started
off as blackmail but then it just ended
up it just ended up as like just
standard like s m right but it was hot
yeah yeah no it was hard but i don't
know i
i'm just not really into like the all
those things although i i did have a
kind of like
shot there for a moment where they were
talking like who took the
so the premises that like she asks him
out and yeah and
the guy says no yeah yeah but for some
reason she has the hit the guy's phone
yeah and on this phone is a picture of
him like in bdsm outfit i guess
yeah yeah yeah and then she's like oh if
you don't want me to send this to
everyone in the school
uh you need to come home back to my
house yeah yeah yeah
right and so it's like oh okay and then
halfway through when they're [ __ ]
she's like oh who took this picture and
i was you know i was having a great time
and
then she goes oh my sister took it my
little sister i'm like whoa
[Laughter]
i completely forgot about that
she isn't brought up again and then he's
like your sister took it he's like yeah
it's like
all right keep [ __ ] me it's like are
we not going to touch it
and then he's like yeah she doesn't want
anything sexual out of it and i was like
press extra down yeah i was like you
sure about that i think she does and i
and i saw an episode two with a
different girl
i was like oh i'm gonna guess that's the
little sister no i mean it was
it's unfortunately this is just like a
one shot that uh episode two is a
completely different girl
different guy it's one of those ones
where this is like god i hate that so
much
yeah yeah because i wanted more of this
i wanted more of this i was very
disappointed that we didn't get more of
this
and because the thing about this is that
for me this one was all premise
because i didn't totally i didn't even i
didn't even think the girl looked that
hard honestly
frames where she looked [ __ ] butter
yeah yeah yeah
the animation was subpar the character
designs were [ __ ] [ __ ]
it was like a cdi game at some point
like there was one or two frames i'm
like [ __ ] what happened to the face
yeah holy [ __ ] i also just like one
scene that i just couldn't [ __ ] get
over is like when he's like first like
he's like you know it's kind of like
doing season like sitting on his knees
yeah he's like all right jack off and
i'm just like how the [ __ ] do you jack
off
i'm like can i at least like put my
knees down like oh my god yeah like
my legs would be [ __ ] like i wouldn't
be able to concentrate
and he does it for like 30 minutes i'm
like your legs are dead
there's no way i'll be able to keep a
boner with this no because what i liked
about this was that it didn't
immediately just go to the [ __ ] there
was there was so much there was so much
build up
yeah and it was it was one of the hand
side where i'm just like man normally
you just want to skip straight to the
[ __ ] but this one
this one made the payoff worth it you
know what i mean that's what made this
like that this is this is what a good
plot and a hentai can be where it's just
like
you you have the you have enough buildup
that you need without it being
boring right but that's because like the
s m like side of things kind of made
like a nice like twist on it right it
wasn't just like standard boy and
standard girl
yeah talking and then against the
[ __ ] like there's a little spice to
it right yeah yeah yeah it was like the
right amount of spice yeah without being
too
over the top yeah also why is it like
when it's it's it's rape and hentai it's
like full on like [ __ ]
for like jesus christ like disgusting
yeah but then when it's you know reverse
rape it's always like
well i guess you should [ __ ] me and it's
like it's like it's like come on
it's really like reverse right well i do
but it's never actually like
the way like it's nowhere near like the
reverse of what the rape is
yeah yeah yeah it's always like it's
always suggestive right yeah
but like this one like i mean the guy
could have left it any time and she said
that the guy could left and she gave him
his phone back he could have left
that wasn't but he wasn't going to
because he's a masculist right like that
was the whole premise
yeah i mean yeah that's why it was
weirdly realistic that's why
that's what it is all right we need to
correct the reverse rape tag it should
be reverse
suggest that you [ __ ] me please
reverse suggested blackmail reign
because there's no i mean yeah i mean i
liked it it was good it was good it was
the first
time i saw a [ __ ] on hentai that i
had on our first one i was like
well you know very rarely yeah that's
hot
the leonardo dicaprio thing with nice
nice i like that